Katy Perry and Orlando Bloom split  et can confirm the couple have called it  quits after over a year of dating in a  joint statement to eat see the two said  quote before rumors or falsifications  get out of hand we can confirm that  Orlando and Katie are taking respectful  loving space at this time the former  pair seemed in great spirits on Sunday  smiling and posing together at the  annual Vanity Fair Oscar party ET spoke  with the duo at the UNICEF ball in  December or they had nothing but praise  for one another she's amazing she's you  know I'm super proud of the work that  she does everyone's a teacher in a  relationship that's how I see it now and  we've taught each other a lot what do  you think of Katie in Orlando shocking  split let us know over on Twitter at ET  now  you